the bigger the underwear the better I
feel you know what a couple weeks ago we
did a debate on whether tighty whities
were hot or not on a man I love the Tidy
whities on a man thank you excuse me
Joey there is someone who just raised
their hand I am I am so hopefully you're
not mortified I'm Drew what's your name
hi my name is Teresa how are you hi I am
so good and I'm even better now that you
raised your hand smiling when I
mentioned the words tighty whities
we can't wear tighty whites today I
actually like a tighty whitey a tighty
whitey I do I'm a child of the 70s and
80s that's what men wore there wasn't
the boss now we ain't wearing them no
more
so you prefer a boxer brief box is a big
well what do you think about this new
trend of granny panties on the runway uh
yes or no no
is